I'm just making you look like a
long-lost member of my Chemical Romance
you just went through some hard times I
[Music]
have never done men's hair before and I
don't really have any men in my life
that need their hair done I mean I feel
like it's gonna be easier cuz there's
less of it how hard could it be I have
ten times the hair you have you're gonna
find out how hard it is the rules are no
cutting allowed no dying a lot but
everything else is fair game
therefore your hair I'm going for chest
loka kind of curly [ __ ] kdramas wind
like those people wake up get less yes
without anything yes most majestic
beautiful creature that I knows a [ __ ]
I'm gonna like stand it up in the bat
hopefully have some wings glitter I'm
gonna try a braid but I can't
maybe I'll part it in the middle leave
your hair will smell good not so much
like a look great cuz that's what every
guy wants hair that just smells good my
hair is really hard to play with I'm
gonna crank this up to 450 degrees 450
degrees he's been a beagle oh look kind
of cool from the back can you see it
from the front I don't know if I can do
it from the front more complicated than
I anticipated
it's very close to my face oh thank you
very much making sure the braid is a
cool look but you can't see it as much I
feel like this is a look well tomorrow
you step into the club and you're like I
have a red when I go clubbing yeah oh oh
oh can't clip that harder you're like
that character from Dragon Ball Z right
now if she gave me Goku here today I'd
be pretty okay with that you're in this
noise my hair's pulling out no it's not
really standing up though
because you have heavy hair and hair
heavier than you think
you really are starting to look like a
drama started it's got a creamy up a
this would even make a really good
Halloween would they would if you were
dressing up like a peacock I've always
been like so intrigued by men's products
like these gels and these waxes they're
quite elaborate I'm actually excited to
find out that my hair can do this
ah the photo what is happening to my
hair his hair is quite heavy and thick
they just kind of all fall down is he
green okay so guys hair is a little bit
weirder than I anticipated you have to
like be so specific with each bit and
then I'm just gonna gather these bits
cuz why not looks like a cute troll oh
you see the amount of glitter falling ha
ha oh God Benny's products are quite
difficult yeah I have a lot of respect
for men now ok I think it does not
alright are you ready - yes mam here ok
ok I'm not hating for sure what the hell
is that what this is not a good look to
walk down the street what a good look
for a concert but yeah I've never seen
my hair like this
Harold you adapt err man I'm like the
straightest hair possible you have some
really straight
even when you think a guy has long hair
their hair is a lot less manageable my
biggest difficulty with this project was
his attitude to just not open